la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation il y
en a t-il en séance
je n'envoie point de procès-verbal est
adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
lundi
aux premières heures du jour
plusieurs tremblements de terre ont
frappé le sud-est de la Turquie et de la
Syrie voisine
ils ont été suivis de nombreuses et très
violentes répliques
alors que le bilan humain de cette
catastrophe
s'alourdit de jour en jour
je souhaitais que nos pensées aille aux
victimes et à leurs proches ainsi aux
équipes mobilisées pour leur porter
secours
nous serons attentifs est-ce que tous
les secours nécessaires parviennent aux
populations touchées ou qu'elle se
trouve et sans autre critère
que ceux de l'urgence
et que la France
madame la Première ministre apportera
toute sa contribution
à l'aide internationale déployée
je suis certain au nom du Sénat tout
entier
je voulais
exprimer notre solidarité
au peuple turc et syrien et les assurés
de notre soutien
madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs au nom du
gouvernement je veux à mon tour redire
toute notre solidarité au peuple turc et
syrien dès lundi le président de la
République a annoncé la mobilisation de
notre pays est proposée une aide
d'urgence des sapeurs-pompiers des
sapeurs sauveteurs et des personnels du
centre de crise et de soutien sont
arrivés sur place il contribue aux
recherches sur le terrain pour aider les
blessés nous avons également proposé
l'envoi d'un hôpital de campagne de la
sécurité civile mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs la France est aux côtés
des peuples turcs et syriens dans cette
épreuve je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous rappelle que la science est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
sur notre site internet
j'appelle chacun de vous mes chers
collègues à observé au cours de nos
échanges ces valeurs essentielles qui
sont leur respect valeur essentiel qui
est le respect des uns et des autres
mais valeurs aussi importantes qui est
le respect du temps de parole la parole
est maintenant au président Vincent
Delahaye pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste il avait la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
le groupe Union centrices s'associe tout
naturellement à la solidarité vis-à-vis
du peuple turc et du peuple syrien et
bien sûr apporte tout son soutien à nos
compatriotes qui sont partis sur place
pour les secours ma question a très au
concession d'autoroute notre commission
d'enquête au Sénat
dont je salue les membres ici présents
et notamment ceux de l'Union centriste
Anne-Catherine Loisier et Arnaud de
Belenet à qui s'associe bien sûr à ma
question a mis en lumière une
surentabilité de plus de 30 milliards
d'euros d'ici la fin des contrats cette
survontabilité a été confirmée par le
rapport de l'Inspection Générale des
Finances qui a été révélée par Le Canard
Enchaîné notre commission
a mis fin à un cirque infernal de
progression de ces contrats contre des
travaux elle a également proposé de se
mettre d'accord sur l'équilibre
économique et financier de ces contrats
monsieur le ministre Clément bonne m'a
dit en novembre dernier qu'un groupe de
travail serait mis en place à ce sujet
en début d'année qu'en pensez-vous le
mettre en place monsieur le ministre et
le premier février il y a une
augmentation de 4,75 % des tarifs cette
augmentation permet aux sociétés
d'autoroute de réaliser un profil
supplémentaire de 300 millions par an
d'ici la fin des contrats j'aimerais
savoir
si les efforts qui ont été demandés à
Vinci
représentent cette somme là où quel
pourcentage de cette somme là est
représentée et pourquoi n'avons-nous
rien demandé à Eiffage
pour vous répondre
la parole est communiste de la
transition écologique de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur Christophe Béchu il
avait la parole merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur de
d'abord je voudrais saluer la qualité de
ce rapport sénatorial qui date qui date
de septembre 2020 qui a gardé beaucoup
de son actualité vous avez cité ce
rapport de l'IGF dans certains passages
ont été rendus publics par Le Canard
Enchaîné rapport qui a été transmis au
président des commissions des finances
de l'Assemblée et du Sénat
je vous invite aussi et je sais que vous
l'avez certainement fait compte tenu de
votre maîtrise sur le sujet à regarder
le rapport de la RT qui est sorti il y a
quelques jours et dont les conclusions
diffèrent un peu pas sur le fait qu'il y
a une rentabilité importante mais qui
n'arrive pas au même chiffre au même
calcul et qu'invite un minimum de
prudence en particulier parce que
l'impact du covid n'a pas été à ce stade
intégré dans ce qui était l'été RI pour
la suite
je me permets de vous indiquer puisque
vous avez cité cette augmentation du
premier et février qui était prévue dans
les contrats que à cette occasion une
des préconisations de votre rapport sur
le fait de pouvoir diminuer les péages
pour les véhicules propres s'appliquent
avec une baisse de 5% et non pas une
hausse pour les véhicules électriques et
vous pouvez je pense y voir une forme
d'hommage à un des sujets sur lesquels
vous avez travaillé sur lequel vous
aviez émis des préconisations plus
largement le 13 janvier dernier nous
avons remporté une bataille importante
devant le tribunal administratif dans le
cadre de l'augmentation des impôts que
nous souhaitons sur les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute là aussi
dans la foulée de votre apport les
sociétés concessionnelles d'autoroute
ont jusqu'au 13 mars pour faire appel de
cette alourdissement de leur fiscalité
mais il va de soi que nous suivons
évidemment ce contentieux et nous
continuons de réfléchir aux meilleures
manières
de les associer compte tenu des
rentabilités qui sont projetées d'ici la
fin des concessions un effort contenu
des besoins globaux que nous avons en
termes de décarbonation vous avez à la
fois pointé dans votre rapport le fait
qu'il y avait une meilleure contribution
à mettre en place et que la
relationnalisation n'était pas la
solution contenue des montants en jeu je
voudrais saluer cette analyse et vous
dire évidemment la volonté que nous
avons travaillé avec vous quand cette
phase contentieuse sera terminée à
regarder ensemble vers la suite et vers
la fin de concession et sur l'équilibre
restant
merci
monsieur le Président de la
merci monsieur le ministre c'est vrai
que vous m'apprenez pas à grand chose
dans votre réponse et malheureusement
vous ne répondez pas à ma question je
voulais savoir quand on allait pouvoir
travailler ensemble sur l'équilibre
économique et financier des contrats
vous me dites pas
clément baume m'avait dit en début
d'année je ne sais pas et sur l'effort
qui a été demandé à Vinci et celui qui
n'a pas été demandé à Eiffage on ne sait
pas ce qu'il représente c'est toujours
pareil il y a pas de transparence sur ce
sujet nous on demande de la transparence
et la défense de l'intérêt général et
nous sommes ici au Sénat 40 cette
défense de l'intérêt général et nous
continuerons à travailler sur ce sujet
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Marie Noël lineman pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste j'avais la parole oui
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres à notre tour le groupe
CRCE nous apportons évidemment toute
notre soutien au peuple
turc et syrien
monsieur le ministre les tarifs
autoroutiers viennent d'augmenter de
4,7% alors que les profits des
concessionnaires explosent depuis la
privatisation c'est le même constat
profitez mesurer pH toujours plus cher
mais ce qui est nouveau c'est que
désormais au sein même de Bercy ce
constat interroge et même d'une certaine
façon scandalise la presse est fait
l'écho du rapport de 2021 très
instructif de l'Inspection des finances
il explique que ces entreprises ont une
rentabilité très supérieure à celle
attendue qu'elle va contre le principe
de rémunération raisonnable au point de
demander à l'État de réagir notamment
dénonçant les conventions et il estime
avoir le support juridique nécessaire
les sommes en cause permettrait une
réduction de près de 60% des péages et
un prélèvement allant jusqu'à
55,4 milliards pour l'État une paille
l'Autorité de régulation
des Transports a beaucoup testé la
surentabilité elle constate néanmoins
une hausse des bénéfices de 47% en 2021
déjà nous avions avec le rapport
sénatorial pointé cette rentabilité hors
norme l'État ne peut plus faire
l'autruche et comme chaque fois quand
les parlementaires demandent des comptes
ou comme le propose notre groupe nous
demandons la rue nationalisation
monsieur le ministre comment justifier
vous que l'État ne fasse pas tout pour
baisser les pH ne mettent pas fin ou
concessions actuelles etes-vous prêt à
travailler avec le Parlement à
l'hypothèse une rue nationalisation
pour vous répondre la parole était au
ministre de la transition écologique la
cohésion des territoires mits
sénateurs madame la sénatrice Noël
linman
pour finir de répondre au président de
la m et c'est aussi la fin de votre
propre question le gouvernement est prêt
effectivement au-delà du mois de mars je
pensais avoir été plus clair quand on
aura clos cette phase à faire en sorte
qu'on puisse se pencher sur la suite et
sur l'avenir des concessions et la façon
dont il convient d'ores et déjà d'en
préparer la sortie
à la question très précise est-ce que le
gouvernement est prêt à travailler à la
perspective de la rationalisation des
autoroutes ma réponse est la même que
celle que la Haute Assemblée a faite à
la proposition de loi qui a été porté
par votre groupe c'est non
la rustine nationalisation
la renationalisation c'est 50 milliards
d'euros c'est 50 milliards d'euros nous
avons la conviction que nous devons les
utiliser
au service non pas de la route mais de
la décarbonation des transports des
reports fluviaux et en particulier des
investissements dans le ferroviaire
dépenser de l'argent pour racheter les
autoroutes ça irait contre la transition
écologique et ça se traduirait à la fin
par une mauvaise allocation des
ressources publiques
je vous signale d'ailleurs que c'est
très exactement la conclusion du fameux
réparti du rapport sénatorial du
président de la haie qui insiste puisque
vous l'avez cité sur le fait qu'il
s'agirait d'une fausse bonne idée et
d'une mauvaise piste le sujet il est
donc de regarder comment nous augmentons
la contribution des autoroutes c'est
encore une fois ce qui a été fait dans
le cadre de la loi de finance 2020 avec
l'indexation de la taxe d'aménagement du
territoire avec la victoire juridique
que nous avons enregistrée au début du
mois de janvier et avec les réflexions
que nous continuons avec les réflexions
que nous continuons à déployer avec le
même objectif de financer via la route
une partie du rapport modal d'autant
qu'il y a d'autres sujets devant nous
autour de la décarbonation y compris de
la route qui nécessitera des engagements
et qui nécessitent d'être intégrés dans
l'équilibre généraux des contrats et des
concessions
merci
la parole est maintenant président Alain
Richard pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances
vous êtes et nous sommes face à un grand
défi pour la France
accélérer l'innovation et la
décarbonation de nos industries
ou même moment la loi une flèche and
redemption actes aux États-Unis a
commencé à s'appliquer
en faveur certes des industries des
carbonées mais avec un double risque
les subventions massives attribuées de
façon discriminatoire contre les
vendeurs européens et une attraction
potentielle des investisseurs européens
sur le marché des États-Unis sur le
territoire des États-Unis vous revenez
d'une visite de dialogues aux États-Unis
en compagnie de votre collègue allemand
monsieur abbek pour rétablir une
concurrence normale et le travail se
poursuit je pense se conclut à Bruxelles
entre la Commission et les gouvernements
pour enclencher un plan européen de
soutien à nos industries en mutation
vers le zéro carbone
quel bilan tirez-vous de la discussion
avec les autorités de Washington sur ce
sujet et quel aboutissement pensez-vous
obtenir très prochainement pour un
réarmement industriel européen en
traitant de façon dynamique les deux
sujets bien connus entre Européens des
règles de concurrence interne et des
aides d'État il y a un sérieux effort de
convergence entre européen a finir d'ici
le sommet prévu demain et après-demain
monsieur le ministre
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique Monsieur le Maire merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur à la Richard je tire trois
conclusions
simples de ce déplacement à Washington
la première conclusion ça nous
surprendra pas c'est l'efficacité du
couple franco-allemand et l'alignement
entre l'Allemagne et la France sur la
nécessité d'accélérer nos
investissements en matière de
décarbonation industrielle et
d'industrie verte et de ce point de vue
le signal que nous avons envoyé pour
homologue allemand robertabeck est un
signal de coopération étroite à la suite
du Conseil des ministres franco-allemand
tenu par le Président de la République
et le chancelier au lave Scholtz le
deuxième message c'est que nos alliés
américains sont prêts à les ouvertures
et qu'ils en ont fait pendant notre
déplacement ils sont prêts des
ouvertures pour inclure un certain
nombre de biens industriels européens
les voitures électriques dans le cadre
du trading et des véhicules commerciaux
les batteries électriques et les
composantes batteries électriques la
corne n'est pas encore définitive mais
nous poussons avec la Commission
européenne pour obtenir un accord
chaussée produit ils sont prêts en
deuxième lieu afin une transparence
totale sur le montant des subventions et
des aides ce qui est indispensable pour
garantir une concurrence équitable et
son prêt enfin à ce que nous préservions
nos investissements stratégiques mais la
troisième conclusion la plus importante
c'est que l'Europe doit aller au bout de
la Révolution stratégique qui a été
portée par le Président de la République
porté par la France en vue d'être
totalement indépendant et souverain nous
avons aujourd'hui les propositions de la
Commission européenne qui vont dans le
bon sens simplification des aides
possibilités de mettre en place des
crédits d'impôt pour soutenir
l'industrie verte soutenir la production
d'hydrogène soutenir la production de
batterie électrique ou de semis
conducteurs sur notre territoire nous
avons une clause d'alignement qui doit
nous permettre de rivaliser à armes
égales avec les États-Unis bien je
souhaite qu'au prochain Conseil européen
c'est ce que pour moi le président de la
République nous puissions mettre en
œuvre sans délai le projet de la
Commission européenne de façon que nous
puissions accélérer la
réindustrialisation de l'Europe et la
décarbonation de notre industrie il en
va de notre souveraineté de notre
indépendance il y a encore effectivement
des divergences de vues entre Européens
il faut les surmonter c'est la condition
pour que l'Europe continue à jouer les
premiers rôles en matière industrielle
au 21e siècle merci monsieur le
président Richard
[Applaudissements]
de la parole de notre collègue Yann
chanterelle pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre elle
s'appelle Véronique elle a 53 ans je
l'ai rencontré hier lors de la
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites à Paris après deux années
d'apprentissage en charcuterie Véronique
a commencé à travailler à l'âge de 16
ans pendant de longues années à la
trimestre sur les marchés dans le froid
de l'hiver parfois jusqu'à moins 12 à
soulever de lourdes charges si bien qu'à
seulement 33 ans la dû se faire opérer
de la colonne vertébrale malgré cette
vie de labeur malgré la pénibilité de
son travail avec les arrêts maladie et
les périodes de chômage Véronique ne
pourra partir à la retraite qu'après
avoir cotisé 44 années c'est plus que
vous et moi qui ne subissons pas la
pénibilité physique de son travail
où est la justice votre réforme des
retraites n'en est pas une c'est un
exercice de rééquilibrage financier
après que vous ayez grevé le budget de
l'État par des cadeaux fiscaux aux
grandes entreprises suppression de l'ISF
suppression de la CVAE de la flat taxe
et ses cadeaux aux grandes entreprises
c'est à toutes les véroniques de France
que vous en faites payer la facture
aujourd'hui même on apprend que
l'entreprise totale a fait des profits
records en 2022
19,1 milliard d'euros c'est plus que les
13,5 milliards de déficits que veut
prévoyez pour le système de retraite à
l'horizon 2030 alors madame la Première
ministre contre allez-vous taxer c'est
super profits quand allez-vous écouter
les centaines de milliers de Françaises
et de Français qui étaient hier dans la
rue pour dire non à la retraite à 64 ans
quant allez vous retirer ce projet
injuste et brutal
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran
ministre délégué chargé du renouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur merci pour votre
question Véronique a 53 ans vous l'avez
dit vous m'avez dit qu'elle avait
commencé à l'âge de 16 ans donc en
fonction de si elle a commencé un peu
avant 16 ans ou à l'âge de 16 ans vous
pouvez déjà lui dire qu'elle ne partira
pas ni à 64 ans ni même à 62 ans
monsieur le sénateur mais au plus tard à
60 ans voir si elle a commencé un peu
plus tôt 58 ans et vous verrez monsieur
le sénateur que par rapport à la
situation actuelle il est même pas
impossible que sa situation personnelle
s'en trouve améliorée monsieur le
sénateur vous parlez de vous parler de
Véronique comme étant exposé des
températures extrêmes vous la décrivez
comme étant exposée au port de charge
très lourdes bref vous portez là un
certain nombre de critères de pénibilité
et dans le projet de loi que vous aurez
bientôt à examiner et je l'espère voter
vous verrez qu'en matière de pénibilité
ce projet de et porteur d'avancer social
comme il y en avait pas eu lors des
précédents projets de loi y compris
celui que j'ai été amené à voter lorsque
j'étais député socialiste et qu'à
l'époque la gauche de gouvernement ne
renie pas les fondamentaux qui étaient
les siens à savoir être capable de
prendre des décisions même difficiles
quand il fallait conforter notre modèle
social à savoir être capable de prendre
des décisions favorables à l'emploi dans
notre pays cette gauche que j'ai connu
et que j'ai quitté et je n'en ai pas de
regret aujourd'hui c'était une gauche
qui était capable de s'enthousiasmer
lorsque des entreprises créent de la
richesse et de l'emploi dans le pays
nous fait nous célébrions l'idée qu'un
jour nous puissions inverser la courbe
du chômage je conçois monsieur le
sénateur que il a fallu attendre 2017
pour que cette fameuse courbe s'inverse
cela peut être vous faire de la peine à
titre personnel mais comme vous servez
j'en suis sur l'intérêt général et
l'intérêt collectif vous devriez avec
nous avec notre majorité vous en réjouir
enfin monsieur le sénateur ne me dites
pas que vous confondez sciemment le
bénéfice mondial d'un groupe
international avec le financement
des retraites déficitaires du fait de la
démographie je ne crois pas une seconde
vous ne ferez pas avaler les lanternes
vous savez très bien que vous parlez et
vous mélangez la même pas les les
carottes et les pommes de terre vous
êtes en train de faire un magma le
groupe Total fait 20 milliards d'euros
de bénéfices dans le monde il en fait
500 millions il en fait 500 millions
sont prélevés par la taxe ce qui veut
dire qu'il reste 350 millions qui fasse
un effort pour le prix du carburant pour
les Français et ce sera ça ira dans le
bon sens je vous remercie
je suis en train
alors Monsieur monsieur le ministre on
n'a pas de leçon à recevoir d'une
personne qui avoué elle-même voté pour
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007 et qui plus est
je tiens à rappeler que la première
mesure qu'a pris Monsieur Emmanuel
Macron lorsqu'il a été élu président
cette supprimer des critères de
pénibilité donc pas de leçon à recevoir
de votre part là-dessus par contre
plutôt que tu as la vidéo vous ayez le
courage de revenir sur les exonérations
de cotisation employeur qui sont
inefficaces contre eux contraindre les
entreprises à améliorer leur taux
d'emploi justement des sonneurs et
surtout taxer c'est super profits
accéléré et on pourra financer ses
retraites
la parole est à notre collègue et rigole
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre après
l'adoption définitive hier du projet de
loi relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable je
souhaite vous alerter une nouvelle fois
sur dysfonctionnement de certains
dispositifs de transition écologique une
nouvelle fois car j'avais déjà
interpellé le Gouvernement sur ce sujet
en novembre dernier
certes chaque collectivité entreprise
citoyens et acteurs du changement
climatique mais l'État par sa puissance
d'impulsion et d'action un rôle
primordial à jouer aussi il est d'autant
plus dommageable de constater que
dysfonctionnement majeur subsiste
notamment dans l'application du
dispositif ma prime rénov
je ne compte plus les alertes reçues à
ce sujet et je sais qu'il en est de même
pour bon nombre de mes collègues de la
part des particuliers des artisans mais
aussi des mers qui font remonter les
inquiétudes de leurs administrer en
cause la complexité du dispositif et du
site Internet y compris pour des
personnes qui sont à l'aise avec l'outil
informatique
imaginez donc les conséquences pour les
14 millions de Français qui souffrent
d'électronisme
les délais qui peuvent atteindre
plusieurs mois pour recevoir une
subvention parfois très endossa de ce
qui avait été annoncé on a tous été
sensibilisés par des particuliers qui
avaient reçu des sommes bien inférieures
à celle promise et ont ainsi été dans
l'obligation d'emprunter pour pallier la
différence
parfois les entreprises attendent le
versement de la prime pour faire payer
le client ce qui les met elles aussi
dans une situation délicate la
Confédération de l'artisanat et des
petites entreprises du bâtiment
indiquent même que certaines entreprises
se trouvent confrontées à des
négociations difficiles avec les banques
voire à des licenciements
or sans ces entreprises l'ambition du
gouvernement en matière de transition
énergétique et veine aussi j'aimerais
connaître les actions engagées pour
améliorer les dispositifs et le rendre
enfin pleinement opérationnel
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique
monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gold j'associe à la réponse que
je m'apprête à vous faire les deux
autres membres du gouvernement avec
lequel nous travaillons étroitement sur
ce dossier Agnès Pen ironacher et
Olivier Klein
25000 dossiers en moyenne sont traités
chaque semaine par Lana et depuis le
lancement de ma prime rénov c'est plus
d'un million et demi de dossiers
d'accompagnement qui ont été conduits
avec
évidemment compte tenu de la masse de
dossiers dont nous parlons à la fois des
axes d'amélioration et je vais
évidemment vous répondre sur ce sujet
mais je tiens à le dire beaucoup de
trains qui arrivent à l'heure et dont on
entend peu parler y compris parce que
quand la Défenseur des droits s'est
penchée sur le sujet elle a pointé le
fait qu'il y avait environ 2% des
dossiers qui posaient problème il nous
arrive d'avoir parfois des dispositifs
publics sur le plan national ou local
pour lequel nous avons des pourcentages
plus élevés de difficultés néanmoins on
a bien deux enjeux comme on rend le
dispositif plus fluide et comment on le
rend plus efficace plusieurs pistes
d'abord par rapport à l'efficacité
climatique du dispositif et le niveau de
performance et je vous indique qu'à
compter du 1er septembre de cette année
il y aura la mise en place de mon
accompagnateur ren qui devrait aussi
permettre de faciliter le dispositif
avec la volonté d'être sur un sa charge
de 0 pour les Français les plus modestes
c'est à dire très clairement sur cette
partie accompagnement une partie de ceux
que vous décrivez comme étant ceux qui
sont frappés d'électronisme dans une
partie des cas et ça ce sera un élément
de réponse concret en parallèle sur le
suivi sur le durée de traitement il nous
faut à la fois concilier les conclusions
d'un rapport de lutte contre la fraude
pour éviter qu'une simplification
extrême du dispositif se traduise par
des risques d'effet de bord que personne
ici ne pourrait souhaiter et dans le
même temps par le fait qu'on puisse
pleinement associer vous avez raison de
le faire les artisans pour qu'ils soient
pleinement acteurs du dispositif ce qui
suppose de raccourcir ces fameux délais
les délais moyens ils sont de cinq
semaines quand on les regarde deux
semaines pour la demande de subvention
trois semaines pour obtenir le paiement
notre sujet c'est donc de pouvoir
traiter ce qui s'écarte de ces deux
bornes de temps qui sont la durée
moyenne
merci beaucoup monsieur gold
merci Monsieur ministre pour ces pistes
d'amélioration mais je vous assure que
c'est vraiment une problématique pour
certains de nos concitoyens et
malheureusement souvent pour les plus
fragiles d'entre nous
merci la parole est maintenant au
président Guillaume Gontard pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre lors de ces vœux en
2021 le président de la République
louait la première la deuxième et la
troisième ligne qui ont tenu notre pays
durant la pandémie parmi ces engagés
c'est solidaires se cachent votre sœur
votre voisin vos amis des milliers
d'anonymes nous disaient-ils Marie
infirmière foi d'animateur Rosalie
vendeuse Thibault agent d'entretien
Florence auxiliaire de vie c'est héros
de notre République était hier dans la
rue et ils y seront samedi et les jours
suivants et il ne lâcheront pas il ne
lâcheront pas parce qu'ils ne
comprennent pas votre acharnement alors
prendre deux années de vie il ne
lâcheront pas qu'un ne comprennent pas
vos contradictions il ne lâcheront pas
car ils ne comprennent pas le sens de
votre obstination et je l'avoue madame
la Première ministre je ne vous
comprends pas non plus rien de tout cela
ne vous ressemble vous nous le disiez
lors de votre déclaration de politique
générale les Français ont élu peut
sembler sans majorité absolue il nous
invite à des pratiques nouvelles un
dialogue soutenu et à la recherche
active de compromis les pratiques
nouvelles le 47.1 le dialogue le 49-3
les compromis non négociables déni
mépris madame le Premier ministre vous
savez qu'on ne gouverne pas contre le
peuple cessez d'appliquer une consigne
que vous savez absurde cessez de vouloir
passer en force cesser d'ignorer les
syndicats les parlementaires et le
peuple cesser d'ignorer une société qui
change Marie Fouad Rosalie sont fatigués
mais il ne lâcheront pas il ne lâcheront
pas parce que leur combat est juste et
vous le savez une seule question les
taraudes quand quand allez-vous retirer
ce projet de loi aussi
inutile qu'un juste
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre vous avez la
parole la première ministre merci
Monsieur Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs monsieur le Président
Guillaume Gontard une fois de plus vous
avez multiplié les phrases définitives
et les caricatures alors une fois de
plus dans le même esprit de
responsabilité je veux vous rappeler les
faits
l'effet c'est que le nombre de personnes
qui travaillent et qui cotisent diminue
par rapport au nombre de retraités et si
nous ne faisons rien les déficits vont
se creuser
menaçant la pérennité de notre système
de retraite par répartition donc la
question qui se pose au travers de cette
réforme c'est la suivante voulons-nous
ou non préserver notre système de
retraite par répartition
pour y parvenir c'est vrai nous
demandons un effort aux Français c'est
le seul chemin pour assurer l'équilibre
de nos retraites et ce chemin le Sénat
ne le découvre pas il y a de réelles
convergences entre notre projet et les
travaux de votre assemblée comme en
témoigne votre adoption depuis plusieurs
années d'un amendement repoussant l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
mais monsieur le Président Gontard je
mesure parfaitement ce que travaillait
plus longtemps représente pour beaucoup
de Français c'est pour ça que nous avons
mené des semaines de concertation avec
les organisations syndicales et
patronales avec les groupes
parlementaires et je le redis dans notre
projet quatre Français sur dix ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt ce qui
exerce des métiers pénibles n'auront pas
à travailler jusqu'à 64 ans alors je
n'ai pas de doute que Fouad marie et
Rosalie font partie de ces Français qui
n'auront pas à travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
et que proposez-vous que proposez-vous à
ces Français monsieur le Président
Gontard une drastique des pensions le
fruit d'une vie de travail ou alors une
augmentation des impôts et des
cotisations ce qui conduit
inéluctablement à une baisse du pouvoir
d'achat et à une hausse du chômage alors
monsieur le Président Gomez de car sans
cette réforme les plus riches auront
toujours une retraite en revanche pour
les classes moyennes pour les plus
modestes ce sera plus de chômage et
moins de pouvoir d'achat ce que nous
proposons c'est le plein emploi et de
meilleurs retraites alors monsieur le
Président Gontard je l'ai dit et je le
répète notre projet n'est pas figé il a
déjà évolué grâce au concertations avec
les organisations syndicales et
patronales avec les groupes
parlementaires il évoluera et
s'enrichira grâce au débat parlementaire
alors je sais que la dirigeante de votre
partie a appelé à faire du Parlement une
ZAD mais j'ai confiance dans la
responsabilité de chacun pour offrir aux
Français un débat de bonne tenue un
débat d'idées et un débat respectueux je
ne doute pas que le Sénat il sera
particulièrement attentif je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
je le président Gautard madame la
Première ministre d'abord ce sont nos
retraites qui sont une zone à défendre
oui il y a des solutions oui il y a
d'autres solutions il suffit d'écouter
il suffit d'écouter les syndicats il
suffit d'écouter les parlementaires il
suffit de regarder de nous dites pas de
grâce aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas
d'argent dans notre pays c'est pas
possible ce n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui oui on peut taxer le capital
oui on peut taxer les dividendes oui il
y a d'autres possibilités
la parole est à notre collègue Joël
guerriot pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoire vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre l'éducation
nationale vient d'informer de nombreux
maires ruraux de projets de fermeture
sans qu'ils aient été préalablement
consultés à titre d'exemple en
Loire-Atlantique 29 communes rurales ont
une épée de Damoclès au-dessus du toit
de leur école
ainsi les écoles rurales sont le théâtre
d'un drame qui se joue année après année
les fermetures de classe pénalisent des
familles obligées de réaliser de plus
longs trajets elle prive les petites
communes d'un élément central de leur
vitalité et bien sûr de leur
attractivité le président de la
République avait assuré en 2019
qu'aucune classe ne fermerait sans
l'accord du maire de la commune
récemment votre ministère s'est engagé à
mieux prendre en compte les contraintes
territoriales la méthode actuelle de
gestion de la carte scolaire n'est pas
adaptée aux réalités du monde rural les
décisions d'ouverture et de fermeture de
classe n'est-elle pas prise chaque année
un peu trop tôt pour la rentrée suivante
il est regrettable de ne pas se projeter
à moyen terme alors que de petites
communes engagent de lourds
investissements financiers pour mettre
aux normes des locaux scolaires les élus
navigatues avec le sentiment que le
nombre de professeurs disponibles joue
le rôle de variables d'ajustement enfin
le système actuel patiente des faits de
seuil il suffit d'un seul élève manquant
pour fermer une classe mais il en faut
beaucoup plus pour l'ouvrir au-delà
d'une logique purement comptable liée à
la baisse démocratique nos petites
collectivités ont besoin de leurs écoles
dès lors monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous aider nos communes rurales
en prenant en considération le point de
vue des mers ruraux merci
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse que papa die
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Gueriot votre question
s'inscrit dans un contexte démographique
général celui de la baisse
accélérée des effectifs scolaires moins
500 000 élèvent dans les cinq années à
venir entre 90000 et 100 000 en moins
d'ici à la rentrée 2023 cette situation
est certes regrettable mais elle conduit
en effet à des ajustements c'est le
travail complexe qui est actuellement
mené et qui aboutira en août à une
stabilisation de la carte scolaire pour
la rentrée 2023 notre ligne directrice
elle est très simple nous nous adaptons
aux réalités démographiques nationales
régionales et locale tout en tenant
particulièrement compte de la situation
des territoires ruraux dans votre
département de Loire-Atlantique entre
les scolaire 2017 et 2022 se sont près
de 2500 élèves en moins que l'on a
compté pour parallèlement la création de
326 postes d'enseignement d'ici à 2023
on va compter en Loire-Atlantique 743
élèves en moins or dans la répartition
des moyens qui est faite en
Loire-Atlantique les territoires ruraux
font l'objet d'une attention soutenue
sur les 33 communes situées dans les 33
écoles pardon situé dans les communes
les plus rurales les plus éloignés nous
avons un nombre moyen d'élèves par
classe qui est de 19 qui est donc
inférieur à la moyenne du département
qui est de 22,5 à ce stade les 33
communes rurales sont concernées par 9
fermetures mais également parallèlement
quatre ouvertures je termine en disant
que ce projet de carte scolaire qui sera
arrêtée à la rentrée scolaire fait
l'objet d'ajustement ces ajustements ne
sont pas clos nous faisons une première
étape en février une deuxième étape en
juin et une troisième étape en août et
je suis à votre disposition pour en
reparler
monsieur guerriot
merci Monsieur ministre j'attire
simplement votre attention sur le fait
que d'un côté il y a logique à moyen
terme qui est l'investissement fait par
les communes rurales sur des petites
moyens financiers très limités pour
pouvoir rénover agrandir voire sécuriser
leurs écoles et de l'autre côté une
logique annuelle qui consiste à faire un
plan d'effectif qui peut amener à une
fermeture de classe alors que l'année
suivante et bien il faudrait la réouvrir
mais sauf que pour la réouvrir il faut
beaucoup plus de monde que dans le cas
de la fermeture voilà le point central
de cette préoccupation et je vous
remercie de bien vouloir entendre les
mères ruraux qui sont très inquiets pour
cela
la parole est maintenant madame la
Présidente Sophie prima pour le groupe
les républicains
merci monsieur le Président d'abord au
nom du président Bruno Retailleau de
l'ensemble de notre groupe je veux
exprimer de nouveau ici notre solidarité
pleine et entière au peuple turc et
syrien il nous exprimons également notre
reconnaissance au secouriste français
partie en soutien c'est bien sûr notre
devoir mais c'est aussi madame la
Première ministre notre honneur
mesdames et messieurs les ministres vous
avez tous ici une feuille de route et
des grands objectifs à atteindre pour
vous monsieur Bruno Le Maire la
réindustrialisation et de belles giga
Factory pour vous monsieur le ministre
Marc féno la souveraineté alimentaire et
donc la sauvegarde de notaire agricoles
pour vous monsieur le ministre Clément
bonne des nouvelles lignes à grande
vitesse des pistes cyclables Canales et
d'autres pour vous Madame la Ministre
Bérengère Couillard la sauvegarde de la
biodiversité et donc naturellement la
protection des espaces naturels pour
vous monsieur Klein les 13 ambitieux 400
000 logements supplémentaires par an
pour vous Madame la Ministre Agnès
panier rue naché l’accélération des
installations d'énergie renouvelables et
de centrales nucléaires pour vous
monsieur le garde des sceaux la
construction nouvelle prison et c'est
très bien et enfin pour vous monsieur le
ministre Béchu le challenge de répondre
aux conclusions de la modérément
inspirée convention citoyenne et
l'atteinte du fameux zéro
artificialisation nette mais au fond les
femmes et messieurs les ministres vous
rendez vous compte qu'au bout de vos
priorités en silo se trouvent ceux qui
doivent appliquer tout cela en même
temps sur leur territoire c'est à dire
les élus locaux sur les mers il pleut
comme aggravelote des priorités toutes
prioritaires et des injonctions toutes
contradictoires pour lesquelles
d'ailleurs ils ne s'excute pas ils
deviennent sanctionnés aucune
planification territoriale ne devient
plus possible tant les priorités sont
nombreuses gouverner ses prévoir c'est
choisir ses priorités c'est donner un
cap alors madame la Première ministre
car c'est à vous que je pose cette
question je voudrais savoir dans
l'exécution des politiques publiques
quels sont vos priorités
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe bechiste de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
comprends votre déception je vais
néanmoins essayer de satisfaire
aux exigences de la présidente prima qui
vient de résumer la feuille de route
qu'Elisabeth borne nous a donné et ça
aurait été contradictoire qu'elle vous
réponde en rappelant précisément la
manière dont tout ça doit se faire dans
le respect de la planification
écologique qui par ailleurs lui a été
confiée par le Président de la
République
d'abord
d'abord pour dire que dans ces
injonctions contradictoires il y a
celles qui relèvent du gouvernement et
puis il y a aussi ce que la
représentation nationale a pu exprimer
ici à une écrasante majorité en juin
2021 en votant cette loi qui m'a
irrésilience qui comprend ce texte sur
les 0 artificialisation nette et dans
les échanges que nous avons de manière
intense il y a à la fois la réécriture
des décrets elle est tactée mais il y a
des points elle est tactée et
l'interviendra au mois prochain mais il
y a des points législatifs mis
d'ailleurs en lumière par la proposition
de loi déposée par Valérie létat et par
Jean-Baptiste blanc s'il n'y avait pas à
corriger cette loi que vous avez votée
nous ne serions pas ici en train d'avoir
cette discussion
il n'était pas prévu dans la loi telle
qu'elle a été votée par le Parlement
incompté à part pour les grands projets
d'envergure nationale il n'était pas
prévu dans le cadre de la loi telle
qu'elle a été votée par le Parlement une
garantie rurale pour faire en sorte que
précisément on puisse tenir compte des
besoins qui peuvent s'exprimer en milieu
il n'était pas prévu dans la loi telle
qu'elle a été votée par le Parlement le
solde et donc de façon très concrète
il y a des enjeux sectoriels qui ne
peuvent pas passer par la poursuite de
l'artificialisation au rythme auquel
nous le connaissons ce serait gage et
l'avenir de prétendre que au nom des
feuilles de route sectorielle nous
devrions continuer à grignoter nos
espaces agricoles ou naturels si votre
question est comment on fait pour
précisément développer des projets et
tenir compte de l'artificialisation la
réponse et l'interviendra dans quelques
jours avec le texte présenté par une
large majorité de cette assemblée pour
engager le dialogue autour de points sur
lesquels la première ministre le 24
novembre dernier lors du congrès des
mers a déjà indiqué les points sur
lequel nous étions prêt à bouger sur
lesquels je travaille à l'heure actuelle
avec Valérie Létard et Jean-Baptiste
blanc avant ce rendez-vous dans
l'hémicycle au mois de mars
la parole est à notre collègue Jean-Marc
Boyer pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre d'éducation
nationale
sur la suppression de centaines de
classes en milieu rural vous avez
répondu monsieur le ministre par des
chiffres diminution du nombre d'élèves
taux d'encadrement ratio et en même
temps la priorité d'améliorer les
conditions d'enseignement et
d'encadrement en même temps le candidat
est aujourd'hui président Macron déclaré
il n'y aura plus de fermeture de classe
sans Laval du maire mais Monsieur le
Ministre la réalité tout autre vous
appliquez des critères qui accélèrent la
fermeture des classes et des cols
rurales avec la suppression de 2000
postes et en même temps le soutien à la
ruralité est affiché comme une priorité
par les ministres forts et Béchu les
mers des territoires demandent une
concertation promise depuis plusieurs
mois la prise en compte de contraintes
territoriales avec la définition d'un
indice d'éloignant et la spécificité des
classes multi-âge pourquoi quand vous
poursuivez le dédoublement des classes
en zone sensible prioritaire le monde
rural doit payer le début d'une approche
comptable déséquilibrée l'école rurale
est une chance pour nos enfants car il
conjugue proximité qualité de
l'enseignement la ruralité nos petites
communes sont aussi des zones sensibles
prioritaires et doivent aussi bénéficier
du débit dédoublement des classes alors
je vous le demande monsieur le ministre
un moratoire sur la fermeture des
classes et écoles en milieu rurale
pour vos réponses la parole est
communiste de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse Monsieur pavèle Merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Boyer depuis la rentrée
2019 conformément à l'engagement du
président de la République
aucune fermeture d'école d'école et non
pas de classe ne peut intervenir sans
l'accord du maire et ça n'est pas la
même chose dans le contexte
démographique générale en effet dans
votre que j'ai indiqué à l'instant votre
département du Puy-de-Dôme va perdre 616
élèves à la rentrée 2023 or si nous
devions
adopter une règle comptable pour
reprendre votre expression ce serait 25
postes d'enseignants en moins que nous
compterions à la rentrée 2023 or pour le
département du Puy-de-Dôme nous retirons
9 postes d'enseignement de telle sorte
que le taux d'encadrement va s'améliorer
le rapport entre les enseignants et les
élèves va s'améliorer dans le Puy de
Dôme nous examinons très attentivement
les 491 écoles de votre département ce
qui nous conduit à envisager la
fermeture d'une trentaine de classes
mais l'ouverture d'une vingtaine de
classes car quand nous parlons de
suppression de classe nous parlons
également d'un solde c'est-à-dire d'une
différence entre les ouvertures et les
fermetures enfin je vous rappelle
puisque vous mentionnez à juste titre la
question de l'éloignement et vous avez
raison dans les territoires ruraux la
question de l'éloignement et tout à fait
importante nous avons créé les
territoires
éducatif ruraux il y en a un qui
fonctionne très bien justement dans le
puits de dôme qui associe collège et
école dans des dispositifs qui
permettent d'avancer sur la question de
la distance et de la distanciation
rurale nous travaillons aux modalités
d'extension des territoires éducatifs
ruraux et c'est une solution qui
correspond à une forme
parallèle si vous voulez à ce qui est
expérimenté et ce qui est mené dans les
villes de manière à faire de ces
territoires éducatifs ruraux un point
d'appui pour améliorer la situation de
nos élèves
monsieur Boyer
ce ministre vos actions amplifient la
fracture territoriale et suscite la
colère des mers et des citoyens qui
subissent déjà les déserts médicaux la
fracture numérique le zan on en a parlé
tout à l'heure la France défigurée par
les éoliennes la Poste qui envisage
bientôt une tournée des facteurs un jour
sur deux le transfert imposé de l'eau et
de l'assainissement l'accessibilité
insuffisante de nos territoires avec le
train et l'avion je ne vous parle pas de
chiffres mais je vous parle d'élèves
d'humains cesser se mépris pour les
habitants des territoires ruraux cesser
se sacrifice de la ruralité sur l'Hôtel
des quotas et des normes sinon mesdames
et messieurs les ministres les Gaulois
réfractaires risquent de se réveiller
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Michael Valley pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre chargé de la ville
et du Logement les nouvelles plateformes
numériques ont sur l'économie la plus
réelle des effets parfois revitalisants
mais d'autres fois ces outils se
révèlent une menace profonde pour la
cohésion républicaine et la puissance
publique doit alors reprendre la main et
fermement ainsi certaines villes
touristiques font les frais nous le
savons d'une concurrence insupportable
entre les logements classiques et les
meublés de tourisme ne serait-ce qu'en
Charente-Maritime on constate par
exemple à Oléron des abus énormes
dénoncés par les élus locaux concernant
la collecte et le reversement des taxes
de séjour ou encore à La Rochelle ou une
explosion du phénomène se produit avec
rien qu'en 2022 plus de 1700 meublés de
tourisme nouvellement déclarés qui
évacent autant de travailleurs et
d'étudiants en mal de logement La
Rochelle justement a attaqué le mal à la
racine et dès 2019 en soumettant à
autorisation préalable la mise sur le
marché de meubler de tourisme grâce à un
numéro d'enregistrement unique et en
instaurant pour les personnes un
dispositif d'autorisation de changement
d'usage temporaire des locaux destinés à
l'habitation pour des locations de
courte durée mais aujourd'hui ces
mesures ne suffisent plus et La Rochelle
a voulu aller plus loin en 2022 en
élargissant son dispositif par le
changement d'usage permanent permettant
de toucher aussi les personnes morales
pour ne pas dire les SCI en exigeant des
mesures de compensation avec la
transformation d'un local en logement à
l'année pour chaque logement de tourisme
mis sur le marché ou en favorisant la
réservation des logements de petite
taille aux étudiants ou aux jeunes
actifs vivants seuls malheureusement
cette agglomération comme d'autres se
heurte un cadre légal et réglementaire
dont joue parfaitement les utilisateurs
de plateforme ainsi qu'à l'appréciation
négative par les juridictions de la
proportionnalité des mesures mises en
oeuvre pourtant avoir un toit pour
étudier travailler et pouvoir vivre près
des siens et le premier élément
d'insertion dans la communauté nationale
alors Monsieur le Ministre quelle mesure
vous engagez-vous à proposer avec le
concours de ses collectivités
volontariste et du Parlement on ne peut
plus laisser la plateformeisation du
logement miner le pacte républicain
la parole
est au ministre de la transition
écologique la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Valais
la semaine prochaine
mardi pour être précis avec Olivier
Klein et Dominique Faure ne recevront
toutes les associations d'élus pour
discuter avec elle de décentralisation
du logement
au sens large
et pour ensemble conformément à la fois
aux souhait du président de la
République et de la première ministre
échanger aussi bien sur le fait de
savoir si les zones tendues doivent
continuer à être déterminés d'un point
de vue national par les ministères ou si
sur la base de l'expérimentation du
Pinel breton des choses de ce type
peuvent se décliner sur le territoire
pour échanger y compris sur la
rénovation et sur le fait de savoir si
davantage de proximité ne permettrait
pas parfois de faire en sorte de mieux
tenir compte de ce que peuvent être les
difficultés qui sont rencontrées mais
pour échanger aussi plus largement sur
les freins à la construction sur
l'accompagnement de celles et ceux qui
ont des difficultés pour se loger au
milieu de tout ça évidemment la question
des plateformes sera posée vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui en fonction de la façon
dont vous êtes classé les instruments
qui sont à votre main ne sont pas les
mêmes et il y a des communes
touristiques je pense à La Baule je
pense à Bayonne qui ont pris des
législations particulièrement
restrictives sur la base du droit
existant avec un succès réel et d'autres
qui cherchent le chemin
nous avons dans les outils juridiques
existants aujourd'hui beaucoup de
capacités à faire avec quelques trous
dans la raquette sans doute sur lequel
il convient d'être vigilant mais nous
pensons que c'est avec les associations
des lieux en nous rapprochant des moyens
qu'on pourrait leur donner sur le plan
local contiendra compte de
l'hétérogénéité des situations là aussi
notre conviction c'est qu'il faut qu'on
trouve un chemin qui s'appuie sur les
territoires avec eux parce que les
situations sont pas comparables et vous
avez cité des exemples qui sont
inspirants mais qui méritent d'être
déclinés en donnant les outils au plus
près du terrain qui permettront d'agir
c'est très exactement le sens de cette
première réunion que nous aurons avec
mes collègues ministres
la parole est à notre collègue Vincent
Segoin pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les labels de qualité de la
volaille française que nous avons tous
identifié comme le label rouge ou la
mention AB vont-ils disparaître depuis
des années les filières avicole
françaises ont œuvré pour produire des
volailles qui répondent aux normes de
production au bien-être animal et aux
attentes des consommateurs c'est énorme
identifié par un étiquetage clair et
simple ont permis à la production
française de trouver une place sur le
marché à des conditions de concurrence
équitables mais voilà que la Commission
européenne a décidé fin 2022 d'accorder
la pleine liberté à tout type d'élevage
d'utiliser des labels sans fondement et
sans aucun contrôle nous risquons ainsi
devoir apparaître des mentions
fantaisistes comme poulet de plein vent
ou poulet des champs qui tromperont
dorénavant le consommateur alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
simple quelle stratégie comptez-vous
mettre en place pour sauver ces labels
et nos filières agricoles
vous répondre la parole est communiste
de l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur Marc fenot vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs merci monsieur le sénateur
Segoin de votre question qui me permet
de clarifier et de vous exprimer devant
vous la position de la France qui a déjà
été exprimée à plusieurs reprises par
voie écrite orale et lors de conseils
européens vous avez raison c'est une
inquiétude c'est une réforme des normes
de commercialisation qui est initié par
la Commission
et c'est soumis aux États membres pour
avis uniquement c'est bien ça la
difficulté ou le travail que nous avons
à faire avec la commission dès le début
de cette négociation la France a indiqué
son désaccord sur différents points en
particulier sur la révision des
dispositions relatives aux mentions
valorisante réservée facultative
c'est-à-dire aux normes de
commercialisation vous avez très bien
décrit les risques qui sont le premier
risque c'est un risque de tromperie
vis-à-vis des consommateurs c'est
d'induire et d'introduire une notion qui
soit suffisamment vague pour qu'on
puisse ne plus valoriser un certain
nombre de nos productions le deuxième
risque c'est sur nos filières en
particulier celle de plein air les
labels rouges et autres de ne pas
pouvoir les valoriser comme elles sont
valorisées en ce moment et donc j'ai
écrit au commissaire j'ai discuté avec
le commissaire nous travaillons avec la
commission pour faire en sorte que la
proposition qui sera examinée le 22
février prochain par le comité d'experts
face en sorte que nous respections ces
règles qui ont été édictées dans les
années 90 qui sont de nature à rassurer
le consommateur à lui donner une vision
claire sur ce qu'il achète et qui
permettent à nos producteurs de
valoriser leur production dans un dans
des conditions qui soient des conditions
de valorisation satisfaisantes et c'est
bien ça qui est en jeu c'est en jeu dans
votre département de l'ordre vous êtes
très attaché à cette filière comme dans
tous les départements où il y a de la
production de volaille nous continuons à
travailler à la fois sur ces mentions
valorisantes sur le fait qu'on puisse
les maintenir et puis donc globalement
sur une filière qui est déjà vous n'avez
pas dit mais je le rappelle mais vous le
savez aussi bien que moi il y a déjà un
grand risque du fait de la crise
sanitaire qu'elle traverse je pars de
l'influence arrière et là aussi nous
sommes aux chevets et au travail avec
ces filières pour faire en sorte que
nous trouvions des solutions de court
terme et puis de long terme avec
l'affaire du la vaccination merci
beaucoup monsieur le sénateur
Monsieur Seguin
monsieur le ministre n'oublions nous
multiplions toutes les occasions
possibles ici au Sénat comme hier avec
le commerce extérieur ou la ferme France
pour vous alerter sur le déclin
économique de la France par le poids des
charges et des normes vous nous répondez
que les éleveurs français doivent monter
en gamme pour trouver des marchés avec
des marges plus élevées selon les
objectifs de la stratégie farm to fork
ou Green Deal bilan dans la filière
avicole la ferme France a perdu la
bataille face aux importations pour la
restauration collective ou les plats
préparés alors il nous reste le poulet
du dimanche le labellisé si vous ne
défendez pas ces label qui nous sont
chers tant pour les producteurs que pour
les consommateurs nous perdrons cette
ultime bataille nous constatons tous les
jours que les normes et les
surtranspositions s'appliquent aux
agriculteurs français et que notre
administration se développe toujours
plus pour contrôler nos productions
plutôt que des produits qui sont
importés résultat nos fermes ne sont
plus reprises par les jeunes vous vous
étiez engagé à faire respecter les
clauses miroirs nous attendons des
suites vous acceptez au contraire une
nouvelle concurrence déloyale final à
nos productions et probablement au 15000
emplois ruraux affiliés ces labels
monsieur le ministre la ferme France
brûle mais nous regardons ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
la parole de notre collègue de Nice un
peu pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la transition énergétique
elle porte sur l'état des négociations
européennes concernant l'hydrogène
batarbonne celle-ci patine pour le
moment puisque le trilogue prévu hier
pour examiner la directive énergies
renouvelable a été annulée et reporté au
6 mars ce texte fixe des objectifs
ambitieux d'emploi de l'hydrogène dans
l'industrie ce dont on peut se réjouir
mais il prévoit que cette hydrogène
devra être produit à partir
d'électricité renouvelable sans dire un
mot de l'électricité produite à partir
d'énergie nucléaire or si nous ne
pouvons pas utiliser nos réacteurs
nucléaires pour produire de l'hydrogène
la France va avoir beaucoup de mal à
atteindre les objectifs européen l'Union
européenne avait déjà tenté sans succès
d'exclure le nucléaire de la taxonomie
prohiber l'hydrogène batarbonne permet
toujours de l'attaquer indirectement
madame la ministre vous avez vivement
réagi en qualifiant cette exclusion de
climaticides et absurde nous ne pouvons
que vous en féliciter car le nucléaire
et l'énergie la moins carbonée dont nous
disposons je note par ailleurs que la
France est loin d'être le seul État
membre frustré par le contenu actuel du
texte aussi je voudrais savoir comment
se présente les négociations sur ce
sujet enfin si la France n'obtient pas
gain de cause serez-vous prêtes à
bloquer la directive énergies
renouvelable pour défendre notre filière
nucléaire et hydrogène je vous remercie
pour vous répondre
la parole que la ministre de la
transition énergétique madame panier
René
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Saint-Pée je
l'affirme nettement les négociations sur
la directive énergie renouvelable red 3
ne prennent pas une tournure
satisfaisante sur la question de
l'hydrogène et je veux rappeler que
l'engagement de la France sur la
question des énergies renouvelables et
sans ambiguïté c'est le président de la
République qui a poussé le Green Deal en
décembre 2021 c'est moi qui présidais le
Conseil énergie le Conseil Environnement
qui a adopté le paquet climat européen
qui fait une large place aux énergies
renouvelables et c'est vous qui avez
adopté hier à une très large majorité un
projet d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables mais je suis d'accord avec
vous il ne faut pas se tromper de combat
notre combat c'est la décarbonation
c'est la défaussiliation et compte tenu
de l'ambition de ce combat nous devons
utiliser tous les leviers à notre
disposition tous les leviers c'est
reconnaître aujourd'hui que le nucléaire
est énergie qui émet moins de carbone
que l'énergie éolienne et que l'énergie
photovoltaïque et c'est pour ça
qu'empêcher l'utilisation du nucléaire
est effectivement je le redis une
position climaticide alors vous le savez
les discussions à Bruxelles risque de
conduire à des objectifs d'énergie
renouvelables qui ne tient pas compte de
cette réalité d'État membre nous sommes
9 aujourd'hui qui ont décarboné une
partie de leur énergie grâce au
nucléaire il n'est plus question de
confondre les moyens à savoir les
énergies renouvelables avec l'objectif
final la décarbonation la
défaussénalisation nous avons signé ces
dernières semaines deux accords avec
d'une part l'Allemagne et d'autre part
l'Espagne qui reconnaissent le rôle que
peut jouer l'hydrogène nucléaire de
notre politique climatique j'attends de
ces deux partenaires qu'il respecte leur
engagement et soyez sûr que je ne
laisserai pas adopter un texte contraire
à l'intérêt des Européens à l'intérêt
des Français à l'intérêt des les
industries européennes nous avons 8 pays
derrière nous nous avons une minorité de
blocage
[Applaudissements]
Stéphane piénoir pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Éducation nationale chaque
nouvelle évaluation du niveau des élèves
scolarisés en France révèle un peu plus
les carences de notre système éducatif
ainsi selon une étude récente le niveau
n'est pas acquis pour 27% des élèves à
l'entrée en classe de 6e pour pour la
matière pour le français et un élève sur
trois ne maîtrise pas les fondamentaux
en mathématiques alors prenons
conscience semble-t-il un peu
tardivement de cette triste réalité vous
avez fait une annonce une énième réforme
au plus tôt une mesure aide cosmétique
visant à créer une heure de renforcement
dans ces deux disciplines sans qu'on
sache d'ailleurs très bien qui sera
chargé d'effectuer ces heures de soutien
sans aucune considération sur l'école
primaire où l'on sait c'est là que se
crée les décrochages et avec comme effet
collatéral surprise la suppression de
l'enseignement de technologie alors
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous révéler
à la représentation nationale
la méthode de concertation et la
stratégie que j'imagine profonde qui
vous a qui vous ont conduit à prendre de
telles décisions
quand vous répondre la parole de
communiste d'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse merci monsieur le Président
de Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur chinois vous l'avez
dit les évaluations de 6e ne sont pas
satisfaisantes en français pour un quart
des élèves en mathématiques pour un
tiers d'entre eux cela nous oblige à
réfléchir à la classe de 6e dans les
études montrent cette classe de
transition qu'elle est décisive pour
l'avenir des élèves et leur bonne
continuité scolaire à travers le collège
et au-delà mais cela ne n'est pas pris
de manière isolée nous réfléchissons sur
l'ensemble du cycle 3 et j'ai annoncé
une série de mesures pour les classes de
cours moyen première année deuxième
année et de sixième pour ceux qui
concerne les classes de cours moyen nous
mettons l'accent sur les français et les
mathématiques en particulier sur
l'écriture un rapport récent de
l'Inspection Générale a révélé que les
élèves consacrent 7% de leur temps
hebdomadaire à l'écriture et donc j'ai
parlé de la nécessité d'insister sur
l'écriture pas seulement la dictée mais
les travaux d'écriture les rédactions
c'est un terme un peu ancien mais c'est
essentiel la question des cahiers
d'écrivains bref tout ce qui fait écrire
les élèves plutôt que de remplir des
phrases à trous comme on le fait
beaucoup aujourd'hui j'insiste sur ce
point de même que l'inspection générale
de mathématiques nous a montré que le
calcul mental était tout à fait
essentiel également en cours moyen donc
nous insistons aussi sur le cours sur le
calcul mental et des circulaires ont été
envoyés à cet effet nous allons suivre
de près ce qui se fait en cours moyen
pour la classe de 6e en effet il y a une
heure de renforcement en français et en
mathématiques on travaille sur la
situation existante avec comme je l'ai
également annoncé des professeurs des
écoles suivant en cela ce qui a été fait
dans l'académie d'Amiens avec les
tremplin ce qui a donné de bons
résultats parallèlement à cela nous
rendons obligatoire le dispositif de
voir fait qui permet aux élèves
d'assurer leur travail sous la conduite
des professeurs au sein du collège vous
le voyez monsieur le sénateur c'est un
dispositif global qui s'attaque à la
question essentielle des savoirs
fondamentaux la technologie on la
renforce pour le 5 pour la 5e pour la
quatrième et pour la troisième
ministre à l'épreuve de grand oral du
bac instauré par votre prédécesseur
votre prestation du jour serait
probablement sévèrement évalué
aucune thèse dans vos propos par
conséquent pas d'antithèse et encore
moins de synthèse en réalité l'éducation
nationale prend l'eau de toutes parts
vous écopez à la petite cuillère
non c'est pas des foutaises et
dans une forme de d'improvisation
permanente dont les cobayes en réalité
sont les élèves eux-mêmes de leur côté
vous le savez bien les enseignants sont
lassés des annonces répétées
ministérielles qui ne remettent pas à
plat l'ensemble du système éducatif il
est grand temps de prendre conscience de
l'incurie des programmes de notre
système scolaire qui forme qui fabrique
des générations qui sont sensibilisées à
des tas d'événements à des tas d'enjeux
sociétaux tous plus importants les uns
que les autres mais qui sont incapables
de calculer un pourcentage et qui pense
qu'un alexandrin est un habitant
d'Alexandrie si vous pensez vraiment
qu'il faut changer cela proposer autre
chose que l’enfumage des mystique je
vous remercie
merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Laurence harrisbet pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président le projet
d'union sacré autour du logement entre
les associations et le gouvernement
peine à faire ses preuves dans un
interview donné au journal Libération ce
4 février monsieur le ministre vous
dénoncez l'outrans des associations
comme Utopia 56 ou la Fondation Abbé
Pierre que vous accusez de jouer avec la
misère des gens à travers des actions
chocs de sensibilisation ces
associations ne se contentent pourtant
pas d'alerter elle produisent surtout un
travail de fond chiffré et documentés et
elles sont les seuls à le faire ce même
4 février plus de 20 maires de gauche
ont interpellé le président de la
République sur la situation du mal
logement et proposer cette mesure qui
répondent aux besoins des différents
publics en situation de grande exclusion
ma question est très simple quelle
réponse allez-vous leur faire
pour vous répondre à la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge de la ville
et du Logement Monsieur Olivier Klein
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Harry Bay
vous avez raison la question du
sans-abrisme est une question qui nous
préoccupe tous et sur lequel le
gouvernement agit et agit de manière
historique je le rappelle encore hier
soir c'est plus de 200000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence qui était
ouverte dans ce pays ce chiffre n'avait
jamais été atteint quelle que soit les
gouvernements précédents ces 5,7
millions d'euros qui sont dépensés
chaque soir pour héberger les plus
fragiles et ce n'est que justice le
gouvernement a lancé le plan logement
d'abord 1 et ce plan logement d'abord 1
à marcher de manière historique là
encore 440 000 personnes ont quitté la
rue l'hébergement d'urgence pour avoir à
toi d'ailleurs parmi les maires qui nous
ont interpellé dans le journal il y a
quelques jours plus de la moitié d'entre
eux sont des territoires d'accélération
du plan logement d'abord 1 et je les
réuni très régulièrement notamment pour
préparer le plan logement d'abord 2 et
je leur ai proposé de les recevoir dès
demain pour continuer à travailler avec
eux et les propositions qu'ils font sont
celles avec lequel nous nous avons
discuter il y a quelques jours dans la
préparation du plan logement d'abord 2
ce plan devra continuer à accélérer la
mise à l'abri et je peux vous assurer
que c'est notre priorité comment nous
allons le faire et bien en continuant à
construire construire des pensions de
famille construire des résidences
sociales en améliorant l'accompagnement
social des familles parce que il faut
accompagner les familles avant pendant
et après le relogement et ça fait partie
des éléments forts du plan logement
d'abord bien évidemment et pour ceux qui
me connaissent un petit peu la
préoccupation qui sont exprimées par les
maires sont la préoccupation de tous les
maires de tous les élus qui sont
présents dans cette salle j'amène nous
n'acceptons qu'une famille avec un
enfant soit à la rue jamais nous
n'acceptons en tout cas je l'espère que
ces enfants ne soient pas scolarisés et
ça fera aussi partie de nos priorités et
nous continuerons à les mener ensemble
et j'en parlerai dès demain avec
l'ensemble des sémers merci
j'entends votre réponse monsieur le
ministre et je ne mets pas en cause
votre volonté personnelle et votre
expérience d'élue locale sur cette
question là ce que je mets en cause
c'est une vision globale une politique
globale du logement qui n'existe pas
tant que le logement sera une variable
d'ajustement budgétaire la tribune des
20 maires appelle à déployer en urgence
un plan stratégique national et
transversal répondant à un diagnostic
clair et transparent que le gouvernement
a tout intérêt à produire rapidement ça
éviterait de contester les seuls
chiffres qui existent il n'existe pour
l'heure aucune stratégie globale et je
crois que la vérité n'appartient à
personne la question c'est de savoir si
nous voulons travailler tous ensemble
et ce n'est pas un atelier du Conseil
national de la refondation tout seul qui
va trouver la solution vous avez déclaré
les associations sont mal inspirées
quand elles tombent dans l'outrans j'ai
la modestie et l'humilité de vous dire
qu'un gouvernement est mal inspiré quand
il tombe dans la suffisance ce n'est
certainement pas le meilleur moyen de
co-construire nous nous sommes prêts
ainsi que les vins mers qui vous ont
interpellés de co-construire et très
vite nous proposerons notre groupe une
proposition de loi nous verrons quelle
est la vraie volonté de co-construire
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue toi de
Bourrat pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
et de la jeunesse monsieur le ministre
en France de moins en moins d'adultes
aspirent à se retrouver devant une
classe devant des enfants pour les
instruire ou devrais-je dire tenter de
les instruire
professeur le plus beau métier du monde
après celui de parents disaient Charles
Péguy
comme cette affirmation semble d'un
autre temps oui notre pays vit une crise
d'évocation sans précédent dans
certaines matières comme les
mathématiques il y a moins de candidats
que de postes à pourvoir à peine plus de
6% des enseignants français se sentent
considérés par la société l'un des pires
scores de l'OCDE oui le climat scolaire
s'est dégradé dans l'école de la
République dans un contexte de
recrutement difficile ce sont plus de
1600 enseignants qui ont démissionné en
2021 au point que le taux de professeur
démissionnaires étant hausse constante
depuis 10 ans oui le respect des règles
et de l'autorité font défaut dans nos
établissements scolaires la France est
le pays d'Europe où il y a le plus de
problèmes de discipline en classe seul
le Brésil et l'Argentine font moins bien
que l'océan dans l'OCDE monsieur le
ministre c'est cette réalité implacable
que dépeint le rapport de la Cour des
comptes sur le recrutement et la
formation des enseignants parus la
semaine dernière qui m'amène à vous
poser la question suivante que
comptez-vous faire pour réhabiliter
enfin la vocation d'enseignants et
garantir à nos élèves la transmission
d'un savoir sans lequel il n'y a plus de
problèmes républicaines
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse monsieur le
Président et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice bourra
comme vous le savez le budget du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
augmente pour 2023 de
6,5% c'est une augmentation inédite et
tout à fait considérable cette
augmentation va permettre une meilleure
rémunération pour les enseignants et
cela bien entendu s'inscrit dans
l'amélioration de l'attractivité du
métier les problèmes d'attractivité je
le note au passage se pose dans la
plupart des pays européens presque tous
sauf deux et dans une majorité des pays
du monde mais nous devons nous attaquer
à cette question nous le faisons d'une
part par des augmentations de
rémunération pour tous les enseignants
et nous sommes en négociation avec les
organisations syndicales pour cela c'est
ce que nous appelons une augmentation
socle suivant en cela l'engagement du
président de la République une
augmentation en moyenne de 10% pour les
enseignants et parallèlement à cela une
augmentation supplémentaire pour les
enseignants qui accepteront de nouvelles
missions parmi ces nouvelles missions
j'en cite une qui est tout à fait
importante c'est celle qui concerne les
remplacements de courte durée dans le
secondaire nous perdons chaque année 15
millions d'heures dans l'enseignement
secondaire en raison de remplacement de
courte durée moins de 15 jours qui ne
sont pas assurés grâce à ces nouvelles
missions nous pourrons assurer les
remplacements de courte durée de même
que d'autres missions importantes par
exemple les heures de soutien et
d'approfondissement en français et en
mathématiques en classe de 6e cela cet
ensemble est également négocié avec les
organisations syndicales je terminerai
en disant que la question du salaire
n'est pas seule lorsque l'on réfléchit
sur la tractivité du métier il faut
réfléchir aussi sur les carrières les
jeunes ne s'engagent plus dans le métier
aujourd'hui comme les aînés comme ma
génération on veut être professeur
pendant 10 ans et puis pouvoir faire
autre chose il faut imaginer des portes
d'entrée et des portes de sortie et donc
c'est tout cela
auquel nous réfléchissons pour faire de
telle sorte que le métier d'enseignant
retrouve toute sa centralité dans la
société française et toute son
attractivité
le mal-être dont souffre notre système
éducatif est connu de longue date le
plus beau métier du monde s'est vu
transformer en quelques années en une
mission impossible et votre mission
monsieur le ministre puisque vous l'avez
accepté c'est de faire que notre école
de nouveau soit le temple de la
connaissance et du respect
donner la parole à notre collègue Bruno
rejoint pour le groupe les républicains
merci merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresser
directement à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé absent aujourd'hui
Madame la Ministre délégué voilà 7 mois
que vous êtes en fonction et je souhaite
entendre de votre bouche les décisions
concrètes que vous avez prises avec
votre Ministre de tutelle pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux de tous les
groupes politiques de tous les
territoires par des rapports successifs
des débats des questions des
propositions de loi des amendements par
tous les véhicules législatifs possibles
le Sénat attend propose et exige des
décisions efficaces et concrètes pour
l'égalité d'accès aux soins de tous les
Français y compris de la ruralité
profonde
argument de votre ministère c'est
l'ensemble du pays qui fait face à une
pénurie de médecins certes mais avoir
cette conception uniforme c'est la
meilleure façon de ne pas agir car dans
la réalité certains territoires
souffrent beaucoup plus que d'autres et
le manque de praticien y est bien plus
important madame la ministre je vous le
dis
patient abandonné et mère à hier de
France ne peuvent plus supporter cette
situation inacceptable et indéfendable
ils attendent des décisions courageuses
et audacieuses qui dépendent de vous et
pas des comités machin chose qui
consomment du temps et ne ramène pas
véritablement la présence médicale dans
les territoires madame la ministre que
fait le gouvernement face à ce problème
majeur
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'organisation territoriale et
profession de santé un affirmant le
vaudou vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur nous partageons tous cette
conviction la santé et notre bien commun
le temps du diagnostic est dernière nous
nous sommes pleinement dans l'action
c'est le sens du cap-fixé par le
Président de la République le 6 janvier
dernier ce cap c'est celui de la
refondation de l'ensemble de notre
système de santé qu'il s'agisse de
l'hôpital ou de la médecine de ville à
l'hôpital notre volonté c'est de
redonner plus de sens plus de souplesse
et plus d'autonomie aux soignants cela
passe notamment par une meilleure
reconnaissance de la pénibilité mais
aussi par une refonte de l'organisation
à l'échelle des services ou une
modification de la sortie du toutes les
deux arbres pour la médecine de ville
nous souhaitons nous inscrire dans une
trajectoire à la fois pragmatique
ambitieuse et solidaire pragmatique
parce que nous manquons de personnels
soignants il nous faut donc assurer nous
assurer d'une chose simple nous
soignants doivent consacrer la majeure
partie de leur temps à soigner notre
objectif c'est de libérer des soignants
que certaines tâches administratives
pour cela vous le savez nous allons
créer dix mille postes d'assistants
médicaux d'ici la fin de l'année 2024
c'est là aussi passe par des mesures de
simplification de tâches administratives
ou de certains cela suppression de
certains certificats médicaux inutiles
nous ferons dans ce sens des annonces
dans les prochains jours cela aussi
passe par la responsabilité de
concitoyens 28 millions de rendez-vous
ne sont pas honorés chaque année
ambitieuse parce que nous souhaitons par
ailleurs utiliser au mieux les
compétences de chacun il nous faut
utiliser toutes les ressources de notre
système notre volonté c'est une
meilleure travail en équipe et du
meilleur répartition des tâches entre
professionnels de santé autour du
médecin traitant ce médecin traitant
doit rester je le souligne à le
réaffirme la pierre angulaire de notre
système de santé ce que nous souhaitons
c'est créer autour de lui des équipes de
soins avec de la délégation d'actes
entre le médecin et les autres
professionnels être pragmatique et
solidaire c'est enfin mieux s'organiser
à l'échelle des territoires et des
bassins de santé c'est le sens du pacte
territorial que nous allons construire
avec les élus c'est aussi le sens de
territorial du monde libéral dans une
logique de gagnant-gagnant nous avions
cela sur les CNR en santé vous voyez
monsieur le sénateur nous sommes
pleinement engagés dans la refondation
de notre système de santé
monsieur rejoint
madame la madame la ministre le constat
on le connaît les solutions tous les
groupes avaient peut-être des
différences vous les ont apporté
maintenant il est temps de faire des
choix et de décider et c'est vous qui
devez décider ce qui apportera la
solution à la présence médicale dans
tous les territoires en France merci
merci
[Applaudissements]
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
gouvernement merci madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le 15 février je
vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour le débat
d'actualité sur le thème quelle réponse
européenne aurait centre mesure
protectionniste américaine la séance est
suspendue